week 12 Saints at Rams 4 29 in the
second quarter second and seven on the
Saints seven
what happens
oh Josh Reynolds touchdown off schedule
play versus a three-man rush you're
absolutely are you kidding me you're
unbelievable now we are gonna go to
this is Sean mcvay's time in Washington
so we're bringing it back to 2015 week
seven bucks at skins second and seven on
the Tampa Bay 24
58 seconds left in the fourth quarter
Jamison Crowder wheel route down the
right sideline
Jameson Crowder we were out down the
right sideline set up the first down and
then how did that drive end Jordan Reed
touchdown in a four by one individual
ISO slant and what meme was that game
you like that
he's real good check out the brain on
show amazing